نتابع الان مشاهد حصلت عليها الجزيره
لاستهداف كتائب القسام اليه اسرائيليه
بصاروخ مضاد وذلك شمال قطاع غزه
نتابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اللهم
الله الله اكبر ولله
الحمد الله اكبر ولله الحمد الله اكبر
والعزه الله اكبر والعزه
للاسلام اللهم سدد يا رب اللهم سدد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد لك يا الله الحمد
لله هم يركضون صورص يفرون الله هاهم يفرون
يا الله ها هو جندي قد اصيب ها هوو يزحف
وهو قتيل في الجب الحمد
لله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الحمد
[تصفيق]
لله هاهم القتلى يتناثر
الحمد لله رب
العالين نشهد ونشهد يا ابناء يا ابناء
شعبنا الكرام اننا قمنا
بالثار والاثقال والقتل هاهم جنودهم
وقتلاهم يخرجون هاهم يسيحون الحمد لله رب
العالمين ها هو
يحترق والله انكم ترون
جنودهم انك ترونهم انهم
حمقا هذا ثارا للمسجد الاقصى ومقدس